more than three months of drama and
controversy over the future of the
Supreme Court is set to end in the next
36 hours the Senate will decide this
morning whether to send the president's
nomination of red Cavanaugh to a final
vote expected early tomorrow night
Republicans as you know control the
Senate 51 to 49
so the GOP can only afford to have one
of its senators vote no three Republican
senators are considered undecided
senator Susan Collins Jeff Flake and
Lisa Murkowski sources tell CBS News
Vice President Mike Pence will be in
Washington this weekend in case he has
to vote to break a tie Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill where the political
fight continues over an FBI probe of
sexual misconduct allegations against
Cavanaugh Nancy good morning good
morning Johnny we should know once and
for all today whether Cavanaugh has the
support he needs to get confirmed and
that's because this small number of
undecided senators may vote to end about
in debate today the way that they're
going to vote on final confirmation
tomorrow as forces on both sides pile on
the pressure all the way to the end is
that justice in a final bid before the
vote anti Cavanaugh protestors spent the
night on capitol grounds egged on by
democrats the FBI investigation was a
sham Cavanaugh's confirmation hinges now
on one Democrat and three Republicans
according to a summary released
overnight by the Judiciary Committee the
FBI interviewed ten people who might
have had first-hand knowledge of the
sexual assault allegations by dr.
Christine Blasi Ford and Deborah Ramirez
for Blasi Ford the FBI spoke with three
people she claimed were at the party in
question mark judge PJ Smith and legal
in Kaiser they also spoke with Timothy
Gaudet and Christopher Garrett
Cavanaugh's classmates who were
referenced on his calendars and the FBI
interviewed Deborah Ramirez along with
two eyewitnesses named by Ramirez and a
close friend from college according to
the Republican summary the FBI found no
corroboration of the allegations made by
dr. Ford and Ms Ramirez
neither did you dish
committee nor the FBI could locate any
third parties who can attest to any of
these allegations still North Dakota
Democrat Heidi Heitkamp announced she's
a no I can't get up in the morning and
look at the life experience that I've
had and say yes to judge Kavanagh this
confirmation process has become a
national disgrace in an op-ed released
Thursday night Cavanaugh admitted he
might have been too emotional at times
last week I know that my tone was sharp
and I said a few things I should not
have said he wrote it reflected my
overwhelming frustration at being
wrongly accused lousy Fords lawyers
called the investigation a stain on the
process because the FBI declined to
interview friends and others who could
have backed her up the report ignores
some of the absolutely crucial witnesses
CBS News has confirmed that the FBI
limited its scope at the direction of
Republicans and the White House why not
have the FBI interview people in whom
Christie and Blasi Ford confided in our
request was to the White House the White
House then made the request of the FBI
to conduct a supplemental investigation
into current credible accusations of
sexual misconduct they did that his
response there gives you a sense of just
how vague the White House and
Republicans have been about their
marching orders to the FBI and give you
a sense of how intense the last-minute
lobbying is up here John we know the
White House
former President George W Bush and other
heavy hitters have all been working the
phones trying to ensure that Cavanaugh
gets confirmed and they will until the
last vote is taken Nancy Republican
Senator Steve Daines has his daughter's
wedding on Saturday is he gonna vote and
if he doesn't how does that change the
calculus right one more curveball he is
hoping that he doesn't have to fly back
to Washington to vote he's hoping that
his party has the votes that it needs
without him but he says he did call
Cavanaugh and reassure him that he
we'll fly back to DC if needed no word
on whether he would fly back before he
walks his daughter down the aisle or
afterwards all right Nancy one more
piece of drama Thanks